We have a voicemail number. That number is
2 1 9 2. David P.. Here's my question for
you today. I ask this question with peace
and love. Is this a joke or a troll? Is this
for real? And if this is for real. Are we
dealing with some kind of mental disturbance
or mental illness? Take a listen.
Hey, it ain't bad news feels. Donald Trump
hot as the president does the fulfillment
of Chapter 6 of Revelation. Please, please
understand. David, the Pharisees and Jesus
this time bribed the Romans at the tomb to
say that the disciples stole the body of Christ.
And that lie has been perpetuated throughout
the Jewish generation for years. OK. Right.
In Revelation Chapter 6 and Revelation 13,
right around the pale course. The pale was
as the voters of pale skinned, polite, pale
haired and his death can. Hades is Mike Pence.
He's going to kill a fourth of mankind with
sword, hunger, peace and death. Try as we
might, OK, to fight him. He will inevitably
win the next election because it's going to
take another four years to kill.
1.9 billion people. You need to put some supplies
on the shelf.
OK. So it goes on for a little while longer.
It doesn't sound fake to me. It doesn't sound
fake to me. And that's really worrying. That's
really worrying because that does not sound
like stability. And unfortunately, there are
many on Cleeves of the United States where
that type of thing is is considered okay as
long as it's couched to remember under the
right religion and you know, you so on and
so forth.
What do you think of that? That that's actually
really scary stuff to me on on a number of
different levels. If it's just a joke.
OK. But, you know, good. I I love it. But
if I don't think it is and it's concerning
to me for sure, I want to hear from you about
it. Canada has had its deadliest mass shooting
in history in the midst of the Corona virus
pandemic. We are starting to hear universities
talk about no in-person classes until 2021.
We will discuss that on the bonus show today.
And we will also talk about the effect of
housecats on local wildlife. A major, major
break, I would say, in producer Pat's defense
of kitty cats.
So much of that and more on today's bonus
show. Don't miss it. Become a member at Join
Packman dot com or make a pledge on Patreon
at Patriarch's slash David Pakman check.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.